good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an amazing
special
unique
day i think we're having a day that's
all of those things because of the work
that was put in yesterday the changes
that were made and if you're listening
to us if you powered through yesterday's
audio i hope we're sounding crystal
clear today or just at least better than
yesterday but i think that we are
because we had a day and before we get
into i literally know what you're going
to say what am i going to say like a
statement on guitar center no actually i
was going to say a statement on you
because this is the hardest working
woman in podcasting she has not stopped
make perfecting this studio we went to
guitar center together but then i had to
pump so she set everything up and you
guys if you're looking to start a
podcast and you have any av needs i
would reach out to claudia because she
is an expert on the situation thank you
so much for saying that i really
appreciate it because yesterday was the
hardest day of my life but guitar center
was a gorgeous experience guitar center
was like a brief reprieve it's just so
funny in the chaos of our day if you are
thinking i need to go to an electronic
store everyone's like i need to go to
best buy and i'm here to tell you you
don't need to go to best buy like i'm
becoming an anti-best buy activist
because it's not the best buy it should
be called worst buy like they have
nothing and it's just the worst store
and i totally forgot like people think
guitar center like just sends sells
guitars no they are literally the most
friendly
well-stocked well air-conditioned store
on the planet we got ourselves a deal
they threw in a couple cords it was such
a pleasant experience and don't forget
about the fact that a lot of people go
to guitar center to like practice
guitar piano there was a pianist who was
just practicing on the keyboard adding
such an amazing soundtrack to our day no
it was literally like the opera like it
was a gorgeous gorgeous show it was
really gorgeous and it really should be
called podcast center because they have
all of your podcasting needs oh now that
you went to guitar center did you feel
weird when you were asking for podcast
equipment i felt less weird because we
were together yeah we're
kind of like just this unstoppable duo
when we're together and it's like clear
that these girls have a podcast yeah
something to say they're interesting and
they won't shut up we radiate like
podcast energy so it's not that crazy
but i guess like me coming in by myself
flustered to best buy this guy's like
she'll never make it in this industry
and also we knew exactly what we wanted
and we had brands brands terms you know
yeah we sounded like experts
we sounded like moguls we sounded like
employees like we could literally like
work at guitar center so just in the
podcasting corner this is like a major
major shout out to guitar center for
really be and this is not sponsored i
wish maybe that'll come from this but i
just really want you to let you guys
know like in a time of need we needed
you and let's talk about yesterday's um
audio
let's talk about it so we used
microphones because you moved you
finally like got to go through all of
your things and we um here's what
happened
because it needs a little back story
okay we have podcasting microphones we
actually have two different ones each of
us ones that we use when we do remote
episodes they're amazing and the ones
that we used when we did that outdoor
episode that the ones that we use for
spotify live yeah they're miniature but
we have two really good podcast
microphones each the problem with this
setup that we were doing is that there's
no table to rest them on and they're not
handheld they have to be on a table but
we didn't want to be like have a big
ugly table we needed handheld
microphones and claudia was like we used
to have those we used to use them back
in 2018 when we did travel audio only
episodes i was like okay well i
have like tons of boxes let me go find
them like we have the podcast
microphones that we already need
so i tested the audio it sounded really
good i didn't think anything of it and
then when it went up and people were
complaining i was like
right the reason why we stopped using
them is because one time we used our
voice notes app on our phone and we were
like this is so much better and
we never used those microphones again
because they weren't even better than
voice notes i have no memory of that and
had i i would have not recommended using
them but we sat here yesterday thinking
we were queens of podcasting with our
microphones i think i actually said at
the beginning of the episode like
podcasters you're in for a premium audio
experience which i think actually
because i was like wow so many people
are complaining that like if i saw those
comments and went to podcasts i i would
think what i would be listening to would
be like
[Music]
and then i was listening to it i'm like
all right it's not the clearest but it's
not inaudible it's literally fine but
it's because i like set everyone up like
you guys ain't ready for this premium
audio experience so maybe people thought
like there was an error like we didn't
know about and at first i was like oh my
god when people complain about like the
quality of our show like it actually
really like it doesn't bother me but it
makes me upset because like we literally
spent an hour and like you can't
recreate it you can't fix it like the
audio that you end with is the audio
that you get but then i was like wow i
guess i didn't realize like we haven't
an audio issues in a while because we
use the same studio every day so people
haven't complained in a while and i was
like wow they like us they
they really like us and like they rely
on it so much that any sort of change is
making everyone angry and so i actually
ended up being like
really flattered that there was just so
much outrage yeah yeah i understand it's
it's engagement is what it is no and
it's like it's like when people put a
typo in their tick tock caption or like
their instagram captions that people
will correct them
and that fosters engagement yeah and i
guess i just never i mean i do know this
because because we're a daily show like
people rely on the show and we [ __ ]
with it and we found out we [ __ ] it
with it and we found out but it was not
for lack of trying and i just i'll never
feel bad if i if i tried my best you
know no i mean you you should have seen
us in the morning before yesterday's
episode i feel much calmer today these
are the microphones we're very
comfortable with these microphones
the best friends
that we know and that we love rode
and i feel and i heard that they're also
uh
i was thinking of that um so i feel good
about where we landed i feel good about
the status of your studio obviously so
much is going to happen in the next few
weeks and it's still just a temporary
look youtube temporary couch temporary
look but until then like a couch is
still a private citizen i feel good
about you know the next couple of days
with you me too now we can just enjoy
the art of podcasting and now my hands
are hands-free because we have these
hand-free microphones and i'm like what
should i do should i pick my nose should
i do sign language i could literally do
whatever i want because i have two big
ass hands yep i can drink my coffee jazz
fingers i know not jazz fingers jazz
hands
um so i'm just feeling really good you
know i like my outfit like i do my hair
good gorgeous thank you so much i'm
feeling good like i'm excited it's
tuesday it is tuesday and it's a rainy
day here did you hear the rain was
driving thunder lightning last night yes
i did and you know what i wasn't upset
because a lot of people have asked me
claudia like how are you dealing with
the heat and it's important to know it
actually is like a couple degrees cooler
here than it is in new york so it's not
like i would you know wish to be in new
york but my god i have not stopped
sweating from the time i landed and it's
just like even the littlest thing like
getting here i got an olivia's car i
drove 30 seconds to your house i
literally need to take a shower yeah but
it's freezing in here today i know i'm
careful what you wish for and i think
that's why i'm like feeling so positive
you know yeah oh you want to know why
else i'm feeling positive i'm about to
blow your mind yeah do you know what
today is
i know what it is it's national anti-day
which is huge huge for the auntie
community and we are big advocates for
the anti-community here you have both
two aunties sitting here with different
styles of auntie 100 but both gorgeous
nonetheless i'm more of like a
smothering auntie i'm the smenty you are
the smanty and i am just meet you where
you are auntie and he will always be
there for you um also can i just say
coming down here um and visiting you and
the kids and olivia and the kids has a
really um and i already knew this but
really stress the importance of aunties
yes i feel like i'm here i'm literally
helping everyone i feel like my presence
isn't a burden i feel like when i leave
you guys are to be like you're going to
feel it like
the weight of everything i'm carrying i
i don't disagree and i'm not even being
surprised you're not exaggerating you're
dead [ __ ] serious yeah no because the
anti it's an important role it's someone
who of course you can rely on can help
out can
shoulder some of the physical burden but
also the ante is there for the mother as
well i've been raising the spirits of
the mother i literally am forcing olivia
and zach to go to dinner tonight i'm
like go like
go put her to bed and then go to dinner
like me and ben will sit she's gonna
sleep obviously they can't leave the
house when the kid is sleeping like
we're here yeah and she's like no no we
want to be with you i'm like who cares
go i will not be accepting no for an
answer okay that's so sweet of you
because that's what aunties are for
that's literally what they're for i'm so
glad they were celebrating
for good times so happy national ant day
to all the aunties out there know you
are loved you are appreciated and you
are respected dog ends too because back
when i was theo's and like that was
exclusively uh yeah exclusively when he
was my only [ __ ] in an open
he was my only nibbling charge
um
it was such a special role it really was
and i feel like dog moms are finally
getting their comeuppance you know it's
our time but i feel like the dog aunties
don't get theirs i completely agree and
i'm here to advocate for them me too
because when i was raising theo aunties
were an integral part of my support
system
like emotionally physically coming over
helping i really don't think i could
have gotten through those early puppy
years without my aunties his aunties and
bryce wants to say
to his auntie that he loves you so much
thank you for always looking after him
and thank you for always just having the
best bryce forward attitude you know
when you're so nice today i am did you
get good sleep nah did rolled yes
king [ __ ] on his king [ __ ] he's king
[ __ ] on his king [ __ ] you guys if you
are struggling with um your baby
sleeping through the night like you have
to just sleep train them and let them
cry it out for periods of a time it will
it gets better better like two weeks ago
the sleep
report that i received today would have
been
a dream like
a fantasy so proud of you thank you
you've come so far we have something
that's enrolled us enrolled tuck and
rolled
so happy national anti-day there was one
more thing i wanted to say oh and there
was one more thing i wanted to say which
is that yesterday we had so much on our
plate this is not my plate um we forgot
to mention that merch dropped on friday
and that it was sickening the warehouse
down like actually the warehouse is
getting tested for covid
the warehouse how did you know
um
sickening merch so many of you have
already got yours but if you didn't know
because we didn't do a show and you're
not on instagram we dropped the morning
toast weekday collection
on
friday friday and it's just like cute
summer fair very country club inspired
it is and by the way i just want to say
so when we launched our merch like what
we were selling on our instagram people
were commenting like finally shorts like
no more crewnecks a t-shirt thank god
when i tell you literally we've never
this is probably we broke our record for
how many currents we sold like
everyone can complain but at the end of
the day we venture out to other
apparel categories nobody wants anything
but the crew next so in case you're
wondering why the next time we do a drop
there will be crewnecks in there it's
because we follow the data and the data
says the toasters want crew next no
we've been following the data for a
while which is why we always do
crewnecks but people also bought shorts
and t-shirts so i'm glad that we
included them and they are really cute
and it is summer so we should have a
short and a t-shirt in there but the
crewnecks always outperform everything
and that's why we are current queens no
matter the time no matter the season you
can find a crew neck at
shotmorningtoast.com and this is our
actually our second time that we've ever
had one but our first time in a while we
have baby onesies the morning toast milk
club and they're so cool harry no i just
wash it and i'm about to i was going to
today but um the ac is blasting well she
didn't put him in the onesie mamas get
her
one supporting you today i just wanted
to throw the mama's getter in her face
just so you can know how like really
scary whenever you say mamas get her and
like you know most of the people who
listen to the show like know that we
joke like everything that comes out of
our mouth is not serious like do not
take it seriously but there's always
like a couple people who are like i'm a
mom and you're disgusting like so i just
want you to know like the fear in your
heart that you feel when you hear
someone say mamas get her to you yeah
but
much like everything else but especially
with being a mama like if i feel certain
about like what i'm doing
i don't really care if i get flak see
that is i feel like a part of growing up
that comes along with motherhood like
not giving a [ __ ] and just doing like
what you think is best but if it's
something that it's like i wasn't sure
about and then i'm like oh [ __ ] uh then
i then i wobble a little bit but when
i'm certain about my choice
can't take me down also um i can't
believe we literally forgot to mention
that we created like the most iconic tic
tac of all time yesterday are we going
viral yet um we're doing really well on
my tik tok we're doing amazing on
morning toast and i just feel good about
it because i know you didn't want to do
it you thought i was like being annoying
with my talk yeah and i get that but you
didn't know that like we were literally
gonna break the internet and had you
known maybe you wouldn't have given me
such an attitude i didn't give you an
attitude i really didn't she was making
me stand outside the car in the hot
blazing sun while she fumbled with her
phone to like organize her tick tock and
it was like you i gave you a good 10
seconds to record me coming in and it's
hot it's not enough time and you know
what
you see now like i had a destination in
mind yeah and you see now that i didn't
need to stand outside the car because
the destination we arrived at without me
sweating in the blazing heat
so you're welcome
and you're the star welcome you're the
star of the talk and it was all my idea
so
you're welcome take tackle ups they do
that's really why i just like milk you
for likes that's fine by me at this
point we basically have a joint account
with how much i just like put you at the
front of it we should just have a
morning toast account i know but like
i'm too focused on building you know my
celebrity yeah if i'm being and you can
always change your handle 100
to like girl with no toast this is the
second time we've podcasted in here that
i forgot to put my drink on my table can
i have a sip of yours
yes but don't use an open mouth like you
did oh my god you guys jackie [ __ ]
and you and you don't go on my lipstick
so that for sure each have a side you
weren't coming after me yesterday like
now that i think about it on the way to
the guitar center not only did she yell
at me for my talk
oh yeah i just said can i get in the car
i was like so with the klemt was running
around all day picking jackie up i had
to work with kayla like all this stuff i
picked jackie up to go to guitar center
and i was like telling her how i'm like
literally so thirsty that's not what
happened she said bring me a snack and
so i brought her two snacks in the car
she ate a chip and she was like ugh now
i'm thirsty so i was like oh you know
what i have a water you can have a sip
and she put her open mouth on the water
as opposed to sipping it with she put
her top and bottom lip oh you know what
i'm talking about as opposed to putting
her like a [ __ ] yeah as opposed to
putting her top lip in you know
you know to be i wasn't quaint about it
like i wasn't drinking as if i was on a
date oh we are both wearing lipstick i
was drinking as if i just got off the
soccer field and i'm six years old and
eating a water you know
yeah so jackie then attacked me in the
car
for being an open mouth drinker and at
that point i just kind of hit a wall
like after the day i had like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i don't even know if
you knew but like as i was driving i was
like cursing you in my head i'm like
she's so [ __ ] mean to me like she's
literally literally pretty good smack i
gave you a water and then by the way
when she put her open mouth on it i gave
her the rest of the bottle because i was
like i don't want to drink it now
because you still had like chip in your
mouth
it's you know what
i had one final point before we dive in
it just sounds like you know what it
sounds like sounds like we were both
trying our best no it sounds like
literally yesterday was just like a busy
day where everyone was miserable and we
were just like
clashing i think that's fine like
yeah sure um but then you know we got to
guitar center and all was well because
the peaceful energy brought us together
nature healed us
so the final thing i wanted to talk
about before we dive in is that i'm
going back on tour and the first three
shows to uh the second leg of not like
other girls tour are on sale at
girlwithnowjob.com they're coming up in
august it's west hampton new york new
haven connecticut and red bank new
jersey um tickets available at
girlsnowjob.com
it is the same material from not like
other girls earlier in the year so if
you haven't made it like you're making a
mistake and you'll regret it for the
rest of your life and if you have seen
it like still come it's going to be fun
there's going to be spritz there's going
to be toasters there's going to be
scenes there's going to be steamy vibes
i really can't think of a reason that
you shouldn't come see me do stand up
because i'm
and i'm not even just saying this like
i'm
literally so funny and talented like
you're gonna die like you're just gonna
sit there like cackling and being like
wow she only has four years of stand-up
experience she's literally better than
dave chappelle and for that i just want
you to have that experience i'm being
selfless you know i just want it for you
yeah
i actually agree with all of those
statements especially like in the female
comedy realm i mean there are so many
female comics i feel like
who would you say is the biggest female
comic like right now it was amy schumer
but it's not anything it's not because
she like took a step back yeah and now
she's performing at the hulu theater at
madison square garden whereas a few
years ago i saw her at madison square
garden proper and now that's where
september
she's at the hulu theater well it's a
great place and i'm happy for her but um
i agree i don't think i would consider
her right now the
the number one like female comedian i
was trying to think like who
there's like a few who are super popular
i feel like i can't even
i feel like the popular like mainstream
ones are like nikki glazer
yeah eliza schlesinger right but
but like the average person would right
you know because they're like they're
big and stand up but not big in like
mainstream pop culture no there actually
isn't someone because it is amy schumer
and she's performing at the hulu theater
so it sounds like they need a new female
comedian who's big and i have all of
those things i'm big and i'm a female
comedian so i think maybe that'll be
like my next you know um
the role is yours for the taking you
know what i've just decided right here
right now
i'm the biggest female comedian
no no that's not what i meant by the
role is here so you're taking it's like
go and get it no i know you're saying
i'm okay obviously but i'm really trying
to wrap my brain on the biggest female
me too i feel like we're missing like an
obvious and when we say comedian that
means someone who does stand up and they
can act and do other things but yeah
biggest
like female
like not kathy griffin
maybe at one point tiffany haddish oh
yeah i would say tiffany haddish is the
biggest female comedian but for now it's
like i'd really recognize and there's a
ton of female comedians like i'm looking
at a ton but i'm talking about like
currently like kevin hart status yeah
performing at stadiums there is not one
no but there's only a few comedians who
do the stadium thing it's literally like
we don't have one female
no you're right it's bill burr it's
kevin hart
it's chappelle
and it's
there are so many male comedians yeah
sebastian escalco there are so many and
the other one that you like
but even i see joe rogan performs at
like stadiums yeah not stadium
arenas yes that's the word yeah no
justice for the female comedians it's
literally disgusting it's yours for the
taking claude that's
okay well that's obviously on my list of
things to do after i've completed this
podcast studio which i'm getting i'm
getting to the end we have mike flags
coming tomorrow we have um just exciting
things coming so thanks to all of our
youtube watchers and if you're listening
as a podcast i hope this is you know a
pleasant experience for the years
i hope so i pray now i think without
further ado it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and i would agree today's episode is
brought to you by upside from cringing
at the pump to getting an eye-popping
check at your favorite restaurant
inflation is hitting us all where it
hurts and it really hurts and that's why
we started using upside upside is an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out with every
purchase we are earning cash back thanks
to upside actually used upside yesterday
because i filled up the shapiro's um
car with gas and it just like reminded
me about it so to get started download
the free upside app use our promo code
tmt5 and you'll get five dollars or more
cash back on your next purchase of 10 or
more
next you'll claim the offer for whatever
you're buying on upside you'll check in
at the business pay as usual with a
credit card or debit card and then get
paid in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with upside
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week and that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store download the free
upside app and use promo code
tmt5 that's tmt is in the morning toast
number five to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more using promo code
tmt5 today's episode is also brought to
you by a brand that we love and a brand
that pete davidson loves which feels
really good to like have a lot in common
with pete davidson we're both you know
huge comedians we're both kim lovers
we're both the faces of manscaped it's
nice
our friends at manscaped the global
leaders in below the waist grooming have
spent two years designing the most
comfortable boxer briefs out there for
your man or you they're sleek they're
soft they're comfortable and they're
flexible the brand new boxers 2.0 from
manscaped takes his balls to heaven on
earth manscaped have the lawnmower 4.0
for the trimming so you can
you and him can wear the same boxers 2.0
for the chilling they even have the
trademark jewel pouch so you know it's
serious i think it's time you invest in
your man's family jewels with the
exclusive offer get 20 off in free
shipping by using our code toast at
manscaped i just want to say ben
software's been wearing the same
underwear since i met him and they were
like an expensive brand and i literally
never understood why he was like so
married to them and i brought home
because we got from manscaped the
underwear and i knew he wasn't gonna
wear them because he's the worst and on
laundry day like he was out of the the
ones he usually wears and he wore the
manscaped ones and we have now like 15
pairs in his drawer and if you're
anything like me like i wear ben's
boxers to sleep because i like help with
the chub rub and i could just like them
so i know they're not really made for me
but i enjoy them as well and they're
female approved but that's like all
products i mean one you love borrowing
your man's stuff but also like stuff
like the lawnmower is for the female in
your life 100 and just just know like
ben is the most stubborn human being on
the planet and he loved them the micro
modal fabric is buttery soft and
breathable they keep his cucumber cool
you can walk you can run you can strut
the moisture-wicking boxers breathe
without breaking a sweat the tagless
waistband hugs his body without digging
in and lays flat against his skin to
reduce chafing
so you can be proud of his underwear let
him wear the manscaped waistband with a
badge of honor get 20 off in free
shipping with our code toast at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with our code toast at
manscaped.com
once the boxers 2.0 touches sack he'll
never go back neither will you
love that thank you claudia our first
story audrina patrick is in the
headlines because she just came out with
a memoir oh called choices to the hills
and back again cute so she's actually
spilling what seems to be like a lot of
tea or maybe these are just like the
juicy parts that people say
right but she details her alleged
flirtations with leo dicaprio and chase
crawford in the book she also um talks
about her brief relationship with chris
pine and that they broke up because of
the hills and that he wouldn't film with
her and she's also talking about the end
of her friendship with quote controlling
lauren conrad
so there's a lot of stories in this book
it seems and i just want to get your
thoughts like are you interested in
reading it well let me say something and
i don't know if this is a popular
opinion or unpopular opinion but
is anyone else getting like hills
fatigue
i just feel like there's like the show
ended a while ago and then like when
when the cast started like talking about
it it was like interesting to hear them
reflect and now it's just like everyone
has a podcast a little goony beach
podcast we were just talking about it
the podcast the book everyone doing like
instagram lives like i just feel like i
don't
i don't care anymore i agree with you i
do and i i totally
there's something about her writing a
book though like if she was doing a
podcast just like talking about her life
and then you know some stories from back
in the day i would have zero interest
but like
i'm interested in this book i don't know
if i will get to it because i'm so busy
and i'm now in three book clubs um so
that's three books a month but if this
were like you know 2020 jackie oh i
would read this in a heartbeat because i
feel like she was so
i guess the word is like relevant at
such an interesting time and like
nothing was bigger than the hills and
those girls were everywhere and like
they had you know the biggest probably
most glamorous experiences like the fact
that she talks about being at a party
and like leo is buying her drinks you
know she was definitely an it girl yeah
and i love to hear from an it girl no
same same same i just feel like now the
kind of the way that i feel about the
hills people
is kind of like has been energy and
they're giving us like so much it's like
we know everything about the hills now
you know yes no there's no mystery
anymore but i do feel like like audrina
lauren kristen
and heidi but heidi's shared in every
single medium that she possibly can so i
feel like we know where they were at
where they landed and how they were
feeling back then heidi and spencer but
i it would be like if lauren wrote a
book about like what it was like in 2008
being the only difference young
hollywood the only difference is that if
lauren wrote a book we would be quaking
because lauren since the show ended has
not uttered a word about how she feels
about the whole situation yeah but
everyone has written books but not about
bills going to the clubs in west
hollywood back in the day yeah so
for everyone except lauren i have that
fatigue but don't get me wrong if lauren
wrote a memoir like all about that time
i would be first in line to purchase it
especially because everybody is obsessed
with talking about lauren like right and
i would like to hear from lauren and
especially because she is so silent
people just say whatever they want about
her like all her former cast mates her
former friends i'm sure a lot of it's
true i'm sure a lot of it is exaggerated
or like their point of view their truth
and i would just love for her to be like
hey guys
here's what happened yeah
because there's here's how i feel about
it because there's mystery there but
with all the other cast mates there's
not mystery and like now i'm just
getting fatigued there's not mystery
there's fatigue yeah she needs to take a
page out of mysteries book 100
so
i do want to get around to reading this
book but i feel like by the time i have
time it will no longer be relevant so
that's my thoughts but if you guys read
it like let us know what you think yeah
and i don't know why i just think my my
stance on the hills have changed like i
was so obsessed when we watched it and
over the last couple years i'm just like
i don't care like now it's getting like
sad no and like with the reboot like
everybody got cancelled right they told
you they don't care but so i think a lot
of people aren't interested in like the
hills new beginnings
but there is interest for like reliving
the past reliving the past and getting
the behind-the-scenes stories and like
what was that really like because very
few people experience that sort of level
of fame
like they did agreed um and i'm sure
it's a great book
and i didn't know me and audrina had so
much in common like we both you know
hung out with leonardo dicaprio that's
so interesting to me i love that yeah
it's called choices to the hills and
back again and i'm just wondering why
the work
choices is that like one of her quotes
from
the show
oh that's actually a good call
i feel like yeah like did someone say
like an iconic scene because like i want
to forgive you if like lauren wrote a
book that would be called forgive and
forget right or did someone say
something to
audrina that was like about making a
choice or something i'm sure that's what
it is because it's otherwise a kind of
random yeah did lauren make audrina
choose between her and justin bobby
maybe like was it she and she chose was
it an ardrina's choice
audrina's choice is the new dandruff
choice 100 which was the new sophie's
choice yeah and
that's called growth
yeah
so
happy that's the new book news
speaking of redheads episode comes out
the first thursday of august we're
actually recording next week so i'm
going to start the book today
it's called a flicker in the dark by
stacy uh willingham i think it's a
danish choice which is always good
pretty good but this is unlike other
danish choices because it's a thriller
she's never chosen one of those it
sounds spooky and i
keep seeing it like on all the goodreads
lists so i think it's the perfect book
for us to be reading i'm really excited
and i've been loving a thriller like i
just want to be i just want to feel
something you know speaking of i need to
address um
some rumors about me
what are the rumors so i'm getting a lot
of messages actually i didn't realize
how influential i was like people um
like i can't find your goodreads help
and i need to how many messages do you
get actually like a bunch every time i
recommend a book i get like a bunch but
look what happened to your goodreads why
can't i find you on goodreads um i have
made the personal choice to step back
from my public goodreads life
um it just got to a place where like i
was so conscious that everyone could see
what book i was going to choose next
that like it actually made me like kind
of self-conscious and i just feel like
reading is very personal yeah and like
if i wanted to read like a self-help
book or like a book on depression like i
don't know like i didn't like that like
everyone could see it you know you know
i do understand that it's very personal
and i completely respect your decision
so i just um i did it and then i wanted
to talk it through with everyone just
let you know like i made a new highlight
on my instagram sharing books that i
like i'm just no longer going to be um
like i'm a really private person you
know so it's just like i need to be
private that's like so shy of you
but i love that for you so many people
do public good readings no i i've said
this so many times in the past it never
like
became it never bothered me enough for
me to ever like go private on goodreads
or even you know
hide a book that i was reading but i've
said so many times it is so personal
that you know the books you're reading
are out there but it's just like what i
said before about being a mama like any
book that i'm going to read i stand by i
stand by yeah i feel good about and i
would show it to the world you know i
just um
i guess it becomes so you know connected
to reading i'm i'm very protective of it
yeah yeah yeah that's how it
goes okay so what are you reading now
the sequel to um
to love jason thorne and it's called to
hate adam connor and it's so cute i'm
obsessed everyone was like i wasn't
gonna read the sequel after the first
one but everyone was like the sequel is
actually better and i don't agree with
that but it's super cute great loving it
i'm almost done that's so amazing yeah
i'm in like i'm in my rom-com era i'm
missing the hotel nantucket you guys if
you're on the fence about reading the
new ellen hildebrand i would say go for
it it was really good yeah i finished it
yesterday and like i've still been
thinking about it and like she really
never misses and even her books that are
like meh which i've read a few um it's
crazy how she keeps churning out premium
content like about the same sort of
thing yeah no she's extremely talented
um my only complaint about her the queen
is she's extremely verbose
and if she could do like you know a
series of short stories like 200 to 300
pages
if you recommend a book to me and it's
under 300 pages like i don't care what
it's about like i'm reading it are you
gonna read tom segura um it's definitely
on my list i just like i haven't been
into celebrity memoirs recently yeah the
last one i read was open book and i
think that just ruined all celebrity
memoirs for me because jessica simpson
was so vulnerable mm-hmm and honest can
i say your coffee again i'm so thirsty
i asked you when you came over if you
wanted a coffee and i'm feeling just
like my coffee's just over there like i
can't just go get it i'm just not
feeling like i have enough energy you
know because you need a sip of coffee to
go and get it
stunning you make such a good coffee
thank you that's so sweet of you to say
okay i'm energized now i can move on
okay are you ready for our next story
kim kardashian and kylie jenner are
joining calls urging instagram to stop
copying tick tock
oh goodness okay sorry i thought the
headline meant they're like getting on
the phone with instagram no they're
joining everyone
the same thing which says make instagram
instagram again stop trying to be
tick-tock i just want to see cute photos
of my friends sincerely everyone so
people are posting this
graphic which yeah straight facts and
kim and kylie agree and i actually think
that instagram might hear them and the
graphic came on the heels of everyone
getting this update which i have not got
what is it marco and ben and my friend
abe called me they were like
my instagram is black i'm like what are
you talking about check mine's totally
fine because i'm always the last person
on the planet on girl in the job i still
don't have comments
like separated by top comments it goes
um chronologically there's something
wrong with my account i swear to god
but they were like oh our instagram's
black and the feed is so different it
looks like tik tok now because it's like
prior it's like reels and like it swipes
differently so a lot of people got that
update and that's why this graphic is
going but you didn't get it is what
you're saying i don't know
i mean i'm always instagram black like
the background you know it's white when
you scroll i always had it on dark mode
oh okay so i wouldn't know the
difference maybe i do have it because
i'm always accidentally like in a reel
of a nobody
nobody yeah
did i talk about this in the show how
i'd get like no you didn't um in my
algorithm of photos i get like actual
nobodies like it in my feed true randoms
and then you all have like 47 likes that
must be like the magic number and then
it comes to see me where's the true
randoms so in my feed
all day every day it's so bizarre i send
them to claudia so she can understand
what i'm experiencing i don't know if
anyone gets it the content has nothing
to do with me it's not even people like
aspiring influencers are like aspiring
to go viral it's like people's personal
photos coming through my feet no that's
bleak for sure
so are they people that follow you no we
couldn't have less in common no
instagram is so weird and every time
they release an update that guy moseri
you know him mosery
adam oseri yeah he's like the official
spokesperson for whenever anything
happens so his instagram he'll go live
he'll do a series of stories he'll put
up reels like explaining the new thing
and he's so manipulative the way he's
like gaslighting us into thinking this
is all better and he does it because
they instagram everything they do now
they say like we um at instagram we back
creators like we want to support
creators we want to help them build
their businesses we want to help them
create revenue streams so they're
gaslighting us into thinking like it's
all going to get better and then we see
what they actually they're talking about
and it's trash and of course anytime an
interface changes people freak out like
remember when every other month facebook
would like rejigger their home
home screen yeah yeah yeah and people
would literally be sending around hacks
to get the old one back but then
eventually you got used to it yes
so i think like with instagram they just
think they can keep doing [ __ ] and we'll
get used to it like i'm still not used
to it yeah that's true but now that i
think about it my instagram story views
are like almost double right now and i
don't know if that's because of the new
algorithm or because like i'm
interested interesting right now people
are interested probably both but my
views have been up as well and like a
year ago they hit an all-time low
interesting yeah they're up a lot okay
if it's because of the algorithm i
thought it was just like me being like
so interesting um that's definitely what
it is like you're so gorgeous how could
you not get millions and millions no no
but i've always been like gorgeous
actually in fact i used to be more
gorgeous um
so me i don't i think it was because i
was interesting and like people want to
like follow my move in my journey um
i feel like that has to be a part of it
either way i'm not complaining you'll
take it yeah i'm not complaining and i
already had my instagram on dark mode so
as long as you can get these randoms off
my feed yeah but now i'm like kind of
feeling dear to you now you're keeping
up like what happened to jess did she go
to her family reunion
did she you know reconcile with her
brother you'll never know literally like
not even it's not even people like chess
going to her like she sounds toasty it's
like a little girl's like instagram
that's so weird and it's like her like
selfies that and she she has to be like
eight you have to comment you you have
to boost it you know her it's amazing
she was too young to even be on
instagram i agree yeah i feel that i
went to her page she had like 12 photos
and they were all just like well you
should go to her page find her mom's
page and reprimand her for letting her
know but like instagram is you're
supposed to be for 13 and up so like not
only is this girl clearly younger than
13 but she's being promoted through the
feed that's [ __ ] weird actually
that's [ __ ] nefarious nefarious for
sure
makes you think but you know what's not
nefarious honey oh
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best ones it finds to your
cart it supports over 30 000 stores
online ranging from tech and gaming
products to popular fashion brands and
even food delivery imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
websites which we do all the time
electronics obviously podcast equipment
um food makeup clothing literally
anything when you download honey for
free using our link you'll get a browser
extension that'll drop down when you're
shopping at your favorite website and
you click apply coupons and then you'll
wait as honey searches for coupons they
can find for that site and if they find
a working coupon which i found that they
most of the time do um you can watch the
price drop instantly it's literally one
click that saves you money and they
don't know why you wouldn't do it so
i've saved money on clothing electronics
food headphones like literally literally
everything i've been uh shopping online
so much right now just house stuff and i
saved actually hundreds of dollars with
honey over the last few weeks you can
add honey to your iphone now it's not
just for your computer you just told me
that and the game has changed the game
has changed you enable it on your safari
and it's literally life changing so if
you don't already have honey you are
straight up missing out it is free um
free to install when you use our link
and it just takes a few seconds so the
link is uh joinhoney.comtoast
so you can get honey for free when you
go to joinhoney.com
toast
joinhoney.com toast it's toast tested
toaster approved yeah
okay our next story little jeopardy
update in the next saga we have our
hosts uh mayan bialik and ken jennings
will continue splitting jeopardy hosting
dewey's and the show will have two hosts
moving forward they'll continue to split
the hosting duties for the popular quiz
show variety has reported both stand-in
hosts have reportedly signed long-term
contracts with jeopardy which will see
them co-host the show as well as the
upcoming celebrity jeopardy series i
mean this is what a year after alex died
was november 2020 so we're coming up on
two years so a little less than two
years i mean that's a crazy long time
and i definitely understand like needing
to test people yeah um
but it's it's kind of messy you know the
thing about jeopardy is like it's
consistency it's not even messy but it's
like this was a whole long thing like
who's going to be the next alex trebek
and it just feels so
weak sauce
tell yeah and it's like
this house
and it's like not even an announcement
it's like they've been doing it and now
they're gonna keep doing it
instead of being like the reveal is here
who will it be behind the curtain and
the winner is
aaron rodgers like it's tell
it's
how no there's something like let down
about it because it's been so long and
then also it's like two people and it's
also two people who we already know like
we're doing it for the last year so it's
just going to be like we never came to a
decision and this whole whole thing of
like who will be in the next alex trebek
is there is no next donald trump is the
moral of the story and i think that that
is a shitty position for jeopardy to be
in because they need the one they and it
could have been either of these two as
long as they made a choice i like it
right and you know what that's what
arjuna patrick's is talking about
choices and jeopardy did not make a
choice and like this bothers me i agree
and i think the reason why jeopardy has
become like a cornerstone of american
culture is because it's so consistent
like no matter what's going on in the
world you can turn on jeopardy at seven
or whenever some thirty um and you can
watch your favorite guy do its job and
now it's like we're a girl well no now
it's like i'm gonna be you know is it
gonna be mime is it going to be ken what
if i i don't watch jeopardy really what
if i don't like one of them and now i'm
watching jeopardy half the time yeah and
i just think there was something like so
cool
about
the genesis of ken jennings being a
former winner obviously a really
well-known one holds the record and then
you know one day becoming the host and
yes that is what happened but it just
feels like a little
like it's like
it's not i'm just not loving it it just
takes the like the punch out of it you
know yeah it's it's not my favorite
decision that the network has made
and i think it's a mistake even if they
said and the winner is mayim i would say
yay miami is the next alex trebek how
cool actually i would have thought
that's a mistake well and i just wanted
a choice yeah no i know and i feel like
and everyone just like sort of never
makes a choice these days yeah and i
just feel like basically they went i
feel like no one wants to make a choice
get your [ __ ] ass up and make a
choice it really um feels like they just
went out of their way to do everything
not to give it exclusively to ken
jennings because it really should have
been him yeah i agree
he was such so the obvious choice from
the second people started wondering who
would take over um and they like threw
him a bone he did a couple and then
people liked him and he was good at it
too like i watched in the beginning he
was a little awkward because he's not a
television person yeah um but practice
makes perfect and he's very good now and
he's like starting to make jokes i when
i was young
when i was searching for stories people
were like he like made it like kind of
like an inappropriate show that's what i
was gonna say he was in the news
recently because he made a crazy joke on
the show nsfw well the headline was like
you're not gonna believe fans are
flipping out and i read it i'm like
that's like not that crazy and it also
wasn't that funny okay so
here's the
joke
the joke came during a double jeopardy
round in the active bible verses
category the clue read since no one had
done this for 40 years god told joshua
to get a knife and do this to mail
israelites and the winner said what is
circumcised and he
this is funny
he said that is correct a painful two
thousand dollars for you
like that's literally like so not like a
big deal it's a word no that's like true
clickbait at its finest that's also okay
so that's what alex used to do like just
insert his personality very short very
small because you don't want just like a
sounding board you want someone you're
in america's homes you know you want
someone with a personality someone could
laugh that is
really funny no and people are quaking
like relaxed also
it's so crazy how people are like oh my
god nsfw and it's like do you see what's
on television these days he said the
word painful about circumcision like
there's literal
like no it's so dumb you know like every
award like it's so crazy what
people watch what we're exposed to every
single day right that's really not that
unsafe for work
like
he called a circumcision painful and
we're all like clutching our pearls no
like if you cut off a piece of your toe
like wouldn't that be painful we're
clutching our pearls when it's like have
you seen what's happening right like
it's so dumb it's so dumb anyways um
congratulations what i was going to say
what i was going to say is like you said
that ken is an obvious choice probably
and he's doing a good job which makes me
feel like and i haven't watched it so i
can't say but which makes me feel like
maim
like crushed it as well i'm sure by the
way because she's a full-blown actress
so she's used to like tv i'm sure she's
very good at like reading off the
teleprompter and stuff and she's a
really
she's an academic she's a intellectual
she's a
neurobiologist or something before she
got famous so she really was a great
candidate yeah and she would have been
great if it was her but i would have
preferred ken just because of the it's
like keeping it in the family
yeah
and i guess their way of keeping it in
the family is to hire beyond my aim
who's like in science you know she's a
woman in stem
[Laughter]
she is and so there you have it after a
year and a half of who will it be
when will it be it will be so
so
it's just like want wonk
that came to mind was weak sauce yes and
the word that came to mind for me was
whatever sauce but that's just the
difference between you and i well when
such comes out with her line she'll have
a whatever sausage and she'll have a
weak sauce and you can choose which one
you want to use because you have choices
and you should make one can i tell don't
use both sauces they don't go well
together can i tell you how um i can't
feel my foot because it's so cold in
here
and i'm not complaining at all but like
my foot i literally it's freezing and i
did text zach at 8 o'clock because we
were gonna podcast at 9 30 i said
can you go fill up the room with air
conditioning now so that by the time we
get there it's nice and cold and he did
it i'm so grateful i'm so cold
and i hate to complain about being cold
because that's like being too rich you
know
you can't be too cold sound like tom
brady um
chilly you're the tom brady of
temperature i need her to lay on my feet
i'm literally gonna have to go to the
hospital that's why i keep pet go right
here it's warm
oh bright sexy man bryson you're the
heating pad now i'm freezing
no my my toe is numb but that's just
like saying i'm too happy you know like
you can't be too i'm too full too loved
yeah unless you're bryson
yeah warmesty that's why i've been
petting him like crazy i didn't realize
go under his belly oh my god put your
hand right there you guys i like i hate
to complain about you know the air
because i'm i'm a girl who appreciates
good air and this is some good air this
is
spectacular so i'll just wear socks
tomorrow it's spectacular
is that what i said no it's because it's
air that's
spectacular
name of today's episode for sure we have
choices it's the name of today's episode
okay because you have them don't forget
that and here's the thing about choices
typically
when you really for most things small
things also there's no wrong choice
you know like i'm choosing between like
hardware or something like small for my
house and it's like don't get bogged
down just make the choice it's really
going to be fine like sure in general
she should have gone to paris lauren
conrad instead of staying home with
jason and there she made the wrong
choice but
typically there's just make the choice
the only wrong choice is not making one
well that's just letting things happen
to you be decisive make a choice it'll
be fine it's really not a big deal
she unburdened herself y'all
she under the burden
i did
our next story klondike has made a
choice and this is the wrong one the
wrong one klondike has chosen to
discontinue the choco taco after almost
40 years
fans of klondike's choco taco including
claudia ashrae are saying goodbye to the
beloved ice cream truck mainstay the
dessert giant discontinued the iconic
chocolaty treat that's been sold for
almost four decades people has confirmed
they are doing the hard-hitting
confirmations
according to a rep for klondike which is
a dream job literally the choco taco was
entirely discontinued in july due to an
unprecedented spike in demand for
different klondike products over the
past two years
like what
no i don't believe that i really believe
they're lying literally even though like
let's talk about the choco taco before
we talk about them getting canceled or
discontinued let's not talk about the
choco taco conceptually
because the choco taco um or at least
every time i've had one which is many
um
they're always like a little bad like
they're like kind of stale the taco part
and what you're saying
is so factual but like conception i just
saw your article like that picture look
show everyone on youtube the picture you
just had of the choco talk no it was
like white go back to that article you
were just figuring it out
that that oh turn around i don't know if
you guys can see on youtube this picture
of the choco talk it's like a heaven on
a plate never in my life have i actually
seen a choco taco that looked even
remotely similar to that they're usually
like really flat well that's like with a
lot of food photography but i agree the
waffle shell is also soggy from the ice
cream how could it not be stale
so it's better conceptually than it is
in um execution what if you went to like
an ice cream shop and got a made to
order choco taco now that is something
obviously um but i just think instead of
you know throwing the baby out with the
bath water they should have just made
the bath water not stale you know what i
mean like work on the recipe i don't
think it was discontinued because it was
stale i just think like people are
opting out of chocolate tacos but i
don't think that they are because if
that's the case then i really yeah this
is what it actually looks like yeah
that's a realistic it's literally like
when you order something online versus
when you get it when it arrives in the
mail you guys can't even see but
if you've had one you know if you've had
one you know if you haven't had one go
get one because they're getting
discontinued what is with things getting
discontinued like it's so final you know
because i got my makeup done for a
wedding in montreal with our friend
lauren and she put on this gorgeous lip
liner and i was like what is it and she
was like literally it's this random
rimmel one that's been discontinued i
bought like 10 of them on ebay five
years ago and now i like use them very
sparingly um
and
on you i've never you know loved a liner
that much and it's just like why why
make something if you're going to
discontinue it you know what i mean yeah
it's just hurtful and it's playing with
our emotions yeah people
they chose that product
now they have to choose something else
it's the thread you know this show is
like a comedy special there's always a
thread
yeah that ties the beginning to the end
and no and then that's usually the title
or something i don't know if you guys
noticed that but that's what we do we do
it um
yeah and no one naturally and
organically but it's what we're doing
every one of these episodes is a comedy
special but i had an update for that
story that i wanted to share with you
hold on which one choco taco because
olivia actually told me about taco
update serena williams is husband
reddit 4chan yeah um what's his name
alexis right alexia alexis ohanian
let me just find it hold on i literally
screenshotted it where the [ __ ] is it oh
here
um he tweeted dear at unilever i'd like
to buy the rights to your choco taco and
keep it for melting away from future
generation um generations childhoods
so if there's like hope in the
resurrection of the chaco taco and our
leader is the man who started reddit and
i have my problems with him because
reddit is a toxic platform but this
could be the thing to make alexis ooh
honey in um get back into my heart or
maybe he'll send a choco taco to all of
the redditors and they'll be so busy
enjoying life that they can't
troll
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
the final story
we have instruments
i'm not getting up
and they're in the cellophane and
they're for harry
he would want us to use them
put your ass on my
feet
jackie anything can be an instrument if
you try hard enough yeah i use my
microphone right your mouth can be an
instrument
your hands could be an instrument
even your hair could be an instrument
your nails can be an instrument
kind of okay if they weren't broken in
frail hey mr schneebley calm down i'm
literally dolly parton
okay our fifth and final story is a
little music news so that's why we had
to sing we just absolutely had to is it
the music news that's brought to you by
liquid iv for the ones thirsty musicians
yep
liquid iv you guys the hot summer months
are here and we need to be proactive
about keeping our bodies fueled and
hydrated making hydration a priority can
help us feel healthier in our everyday
lives one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone
plus liquid iv products taste great with
10 refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch liquid iv is a fabulous hydrating
product basically you put the packet
into 16 ounces of water and it'll
hydrate you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone it's also
great because it's packed with vitamins
b3 b5
b6 b12 vitamin c it has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks which makes it a great thing to
drink if you're hungover trust me i'm an
expert like the unofficial hangover
beverage i know you know and also if you
just like aren't good at keeping
yourself hydrated constantly like be
more time efficient like time management
is important instead of drinking one
bottle of water drink a bottle of water
with
liquid ivs that way you're getting
electrolytes you're getting vitamins
you're getting hydrated better and
faster
um grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com use
code toast at checkout and that's 25 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration today using promo code toast
at liquidive.com
great our fifth and final story
eurovision song contest 2023 will be
hosted in the uk on behalf of ukraine so
next year's eurovision was supposed to
be in the ukraine because a ukrainian
folk group won this year and that's how
it works like whoever wins hosts the
next year right and they can't uh host
it in war-torn ukraine right now so the
uk will be picking up the mantle because
sam ryder came in second place and uk
came in second place so so much to
unpack here first of all i didn't even
realize eurovision 2022 happened me
neither last year eurovision was like
such a big part of my i loved the
experience like being a part of
something and then i would like hear the
eurovision songs and i was like oh i
watch yeah i watch eurovision yeah and i
didn't even know that it happened i
googled it it happened in may no same
and i like follow sam ryder the uk guy i
really really like him and i knew he was
the representative for the uk and i was
so excited for him and i was like ready
to watch literally had not one idea that
it had already happened was it not
streamed on peacock again like it was
last year because you're you know our
resident eurovision you didn't even know
no i had no [ __ ] idea so
excited for 2023 like someone get the
rights please because we love eurofish
in here and i love sam ryder and this is
just one of those like rare occurrences
where like
not um what's the word i'm looking for
like not political but like um
world events yeah like colliding with
and like in changing i feel like it
happens sometimes with the olympics like
impacting like social events pop culture
um so that's interesting and i
i didn't know that ukraine had won but
if i had watched and saw them win i
would have imagined they wouldn't have
been able to host yeah but the one in
the uk i think will have a lot of
ukrainian elements and they it will be
as if it's in the ukraine you know
they're gonna honor you it's not gonna
be like union jack it's not gonna be the
queen's jubilee no no no they're going
to honor the ukraine right right as they
should so um i think that's great i love
eurovision like okay when i love sam
writer and did you know that he came in
second place with a called a song called
spaceman which is pronounced
do you know that he that's the song he's
saying at the queen's jubilee that we
watched
when he was wearing that union jacket i
listened to it this morning because i
was like this was all new news it's so
crazy like we're so plugged in yet when
i read the story i was like eurovision
happened
ukraine won i didn't even hear ukraine
one yeah like where was eurovision
anyway so then i was like okay i want to
hear this song spaceman and it did it
didn't sound like you know when you
listen to a song for the first time and
it's like mambo jumbo no it's just like
words right so it did sound like a song
to me and that is because it was at the
queen's jubilee also um really really
quick what did i want to say oh i know
obviously it's eurovision so it has
nothing to do with us
please let us get involved i would love
for us to be a part of it like to root
for america um and i totally get why we
can't whatever but it's like i'm kind of
jealous that we don't have that and i
think nbc recently tried to do their own
version of that with the great american
song contest oh and that they had
because i was just thinking we should
have a you know america vision that's
every state sends his representative and
then i was thinking didn't someone just
try to do that and they tried their best
because they had queen kelly clarkson be
the host which means like that's as good
as it's gonna get it wasn't ever gonna
get a better host um but it was on nbc
and it didn't feel like the thing with
eurovision it's like it's a part of the
government like it's not like uh you
know
cbs europe
like it's it's just integrated into
culture so much whereas like this nbc
one they like cast people it just didn't
feel as authentic like the crazy thing
about eurovision is like i think you
have to be selected by like your prime
minister like it's so a part of european
culture and like it's a part of like the
parliament and [ __ ] like it's cool yeah
that is it didn't feel official the
great american it just felt like another
the voice yeah i agree or like catching
kelsey we're sending one girl from every
state and i didn't even know who won
yeah but i like this idea okay try again
and if you do it right like come to us
and it's done and they'll get involved i
think like whenever the government does
something they like mess it up because
they're like solo budget and gross but
like it needs to be like the department
of arts you know what i mean like
something like that yeah i agree i don't
know if there's an art department in the
government but but i do feel like and
with the one time i did watch eurovision
like it does feel kind of political like
the people that each country votes for
like they actually weren't like the most
talented oh and so i do think the fact
that it's official and political makes
it legit but it also makes it so that
it's not really merit-based it's just
like countries that are allies voting
for each other when we were watching and
then the voting happened like there was
clearly three or four acts that were the
best and then everyone would come out
with their votes and basically how it
works is like you give you know
second place whoever you thought was
like the third best gets five votes
whoever you thought was the second best
gets ten votes whoever you thought was
the first best will get 20 votes and it
was like all these [ __ ] random
countries like not obviously like the
best ones no like
so that was frustrating i agree i i find
the scoring on eurovision maybe this is
just us not being european and not
really understanding it because i've
only watched like the last three years
but people in europe literally are like
raised on it maybe they understand it
more i do not understand the um scoring
at all no the scoring i like that you
know everyone gets points no but like i
don't understand like who's considered
good because i'm like that person's
stunk right i just feel like you guys
are friends like you're a neighboring
country no but maybe it's really just
like our american taste in music and
culture
maybe maybe maybe maybe they like
different things in malta i loved malta
2021 by the way same and she was robbed
a hundred percent she was robbed yeah
and there's actually a lot of people um
who like are now in mainstream
especially in america like in popular
culture who are from
eurovision main skin yeah i want you one
but when they won i was like what did we
watch the same thing literally same i'm
like who is this but are they that band
are they that talented they are like
they're so popular also the girl in who
won when it was in tel aviv the next
year neta her songs are so viral on tik
tok like she's the biggest pop star in
israel like there actually are a lot of
people and a lot of songs that you know
and you don't realize they originated in
eurovision yeah there's a ton from tik
tok and um social media yeah and i yeah
i can't think of them right now but i i
do know like i'm jealous like i feel
left out like i'm definitely having fomo
and i'd like to be a part of it yeah
that's true but at least you um you can
root for israel
yeah that's true
so those were the past five you
definitely did not need to know them but
you did need to hang out with your girls
for an hour and now it's lunchtime i
think you needed to know them like
audrina patridge has written her memoirs
do without what you will eurovision has
moved to the uk and by the way it
happened this year you needed to know
and you need to know that you have
choices and you should make them and
don't let them pass you by a hundred
percent and you also know about like
it's national anti-day you need to know
that but life is really just an
amalgamation of your choices you know
what i'm loving audrina patrick's title
i'm loving it girl i i feel you i need
to read this book now um
and i need to put a sock on my foot
no i literally need to go to a sauna
because and i don't want to complain
like i hate
that's like saying you know something is
too good you know this meal is too good
yeah room is too cold well you could
have a meal that's like too rich and
it's good it's too much but i didn't say
rich i said good it's too much goodness
um that's like saying bryce is too cute
you know it's not possible you can't
have too much of a good thing
so that's our show
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday your pleasant
listening experience today every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please we're
working so hard on our set [ __ ]
subscribe okay we're almost at 90k we're
like five people away also if you're
listening as a podcast we're available
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes signature public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places
where we listen to podcast find us the
morning just leave the five star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are hope you guys have an enclave
tuesday and we'll see you tomorrow don't
let it be anything less than in crab
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day a
new episode of breaking bread tomorrow
night and i think tomorrow for hump day
theo she'll be here yeah he didn't want
to come today i didn't want to bring
both dogs in the studio yesterday today
until we like had good audio good video
so because theo just he wants to walk
into success he doesn't want to be a
part of building it it's
about it's below his pay grade 100
so bye love you love you bye